when you brought this to the to the
venture community how did they react
they understand open source enough now
to see this path clearly this playbook
yeah you know it was interesting it's it
was an interesting time because you know
I think the open source companies were
not that well understood beyond that it
wasn't even clear what the category of
thing we were had was we so we could say
okay look this is really popular and
they would be like well is it database
well kind of yeah but really different
you know is it and so so it was a
definitely work to explain it and then
you know but that I think like the the
venture community generally responds
well to traction you know the one thing
you can't BS your way through is like
real people doing valuable things with
your product whatever it is yeah that
they the attention of smart people on
the platform smart people are not going
to engage to do you a favor or you're
not gonna be able to fake that yeah you
know I think if you're in the business
of having people come and tell you
hopeful stories all day long you kind of
get you start to just discount it and so
the things that are hard to fake I think
are the things that people believe most
in so that was one of our big learnings
in the early fundraising was we would go
through this long pitch about why this
was all inevitable at the last slide we
would show some traction which was
amazing for this open-source project and
then you know the whole time the venture
people would be like on their phones not
paying attention the last slide they're
like holy [ __ ] so so then we're like put
that yeah put that up right that was a
it's interesting I wrote a blog post
recently I was like if you want to close
funding immediately have this chart and
yeah the chart is we're doubling every
four months yeah because any company
that can double every three four five
months you know with whatever amount of
resources to have if given more
resources they could grow faster
you've been year-over-year what's the
revenue growth like at a company like
yours to hit these kind of levels you
know quorum levels he's right yeah we
you know chronically over 3x you know
closer to about 3 and 1/2 X last year to
this year
Wow yeah so 2019 versus 2018 is gonna be
3 X uh 2017 2018 was 3 yeah 2019 is
still happening yeah you think you can
do another 3 extra more like a to it
we're going pretty quick so so we'll see
harder as you get the numbers get bigger
that's right that's right this yeah this
last year we're definitely getting to
scale you know the companies like five
hundred people all we have a bunch copy
based yeah
well everywhere you know the
headquarters is in Palo Alto
but we have an office up here in San
Francisco we've got offices in London we
got really folks all around the world